Consider the following group of drainage
areas and the corresponding intensity
duration frequency curves provided for
the region based on the provided times
of concentration for each drainage area
as well as the travel time between
drainage areas. The design rainfall
intensity in inches per hour for the
25-year storm at point C is most nearly
what?
So, some of you probably understand what
to do with this problem based on the
problem statement. But for those of you
who forget what time of concentration
is, you can still search for that term
in the reference manual to find the
following definition.
The time of concentration is going to be
the time required for the runoff to
travel from the hydraulically most
distant point of the watershed to the
point of interest in
minutes. So let's apply this definition
by summing some combinations of drainage
areas and travel times to find the
longest.
The first thing we can do is recognize
that since two drainage areas are
draining to each point A, B, and C, we
can save some time by only summing the
longer of the two. So we can see that 6
is greater than 4. So let's ignore
drainage area 2. So for drainage area 1,
the overland flow to point A will take 6
minutes. Then we will take three minutes
to go from A to B and six more minutes
to go from B to C. This will give us 15
minutes. Next, we can see that drainage
area 4 is the longer of the two that
drain to point
B. So, we can add 2
minutes to the 6 minutes from point B to
C.
to get 8
minutes. Finally, we can see that
drainage area 6 is the longer of the two
drainage areas that drain directly to
point C. We only need the 20inut
overland flow time here since we have no
additional travel time required to get
to point C.
So we can see that although drainage
area 6 is the closest physical distance
to point C, it actually has the longest
time of concentration or the way our
definition explains it is the
hydraulically most distant point. So, if
we take that number of 20 minutes and
trace up on our intensity, duration,
frequency plot to the line for the
25-year storm and then trace over to the
intensity that corresponds to
it. We can see that our answer is about
1.7 in hour or the third answer of our
list.
So all it takes to solve this problem is
an understanding of time of
concentration. It might feel weird to
pick the closest physical point to the
point in
question, but a lot of PE problems are
designed to make sure that you
understand exactly what you're looking
for. And in this case, we were looking
for the hydraulically most distant
point. And that's all it takes to solve
this problem.